it's time for ej
presented by no one unsullied by
sponsorship since 1989. thank you dr
o'neal uh have you guys heard of
flulaborg
who lula borg what's that he is a
german comedian uh he's an actor
he's a musician and he's a huge
basketball fan
and especially apparently of our show
so this this one out there on on social
media
i just did watch once more my most
favorite
show of television history it is
inside of the nba is the title
it is very great the people's on the
show i'm loving very hard
i love kenneth the airplane smith
and ej yeah the
[Music]
charles bartles you know the surround
rebound of
ground i love so many things in the show
you know it's sharky the fool what
it's shacky the fool what it's sharky
the fool what
i like to eat cookies or something and
then of course
each a the escalator is having also a
segment you know
each anito knight of the stats present
by no person
and look who's joining us from los
angeles california none other than
lula borg thank you so much uh and
who would have thought you would you
would be the neato stat of the night
or night of this oh and it's always like
inception guys i feel like christopher
nolan is directing this this is so
wonderful
thank you very much we love the graphics
behind you too those
are very nice inside of the nba i'm a
little confused i thought this was
my job interview so i was prepared for
that sorry about that guys
but i'm ready for any questions or
anything so
hello
hey so what part of germany are you from
yes mr buckley i am from
erlangen it's a very tiny town but let
me tell you we have delicious
foods you would love it and uh we have
very much watched all of your delicious
hoops
when you elbowed peoples from angola and
said watch out here comes the troubles
it was great actually i actually germany
uh i've been to munich
which i loved and there was another is
it dortmund
oh yes it's dortmund yeah yes absolutely
they've got bratwurst rhinesworth
currywurst
palm fritz and veena schnitzel all of
the worsts oh we have some we have worse
more days worse for fodder
kenny's not with us tonight i flew lula
but we do have draymond green of the
golden state warriors
you can't be that big of a fan if you
didn't check
instagram today you should have known i
was going to be here so i don't really
have a question for you
but i have a question for you tremont
are you ready
no okay well then here it comes anyplace
i was i was speaking to bob earlier
myers
and uh he was not taking my calls i was
wondering if you could perhaps
ask him if instead of hiring an
additional splash brother
perhaps a splash nephew or a splash
uncle as a splunker
i am i am available and ready for the
snoopy snoop swishers
[Laughter]
uh flu i'm i'm still trying to catch the
splash title
so i i don't think my recommendations
hold any weight there my friend
that depresses me deeply even though you
are defensive player of the year you
have no way it's what's going on mr
green
you say splash you didn't say defense
they don't rhyme that's very true
i would understand flula that you are a
huge dirk nowitzki fan huh
all the most massive he is the german
moses uh he is the best basketball
player in the history of everyone that
was born east of the mississippi rivers
i'm so excited and i i know you guys
loves him here barkley i know you guys
um are all loving him as well he's the
best
yeah wait so you say he's like moses you
mean moses him alone or moses the dude
in the bible
oh the bible dude i wrote the techno
song about him yes
and no no moses malone your former
teammate three-time mvp
these are very different skill sets i
would never compare these two very sassy
dudes
i i understand also flula that you have
uh you've been working very hard on on a
on a techno song with with sir charles
i have been working for it um one very
quick question um ernie
why are you called the escalator is it
bad knees or what is the source
uh it was actually uh my nickname for a
slam dunk contest and it was the
elevator
not the escalator but the escalator is
probably closer to it than
the elevator different mode of
transportation okay
you're absolutely right so you got this
song ready for us to uh
absolutely um mr bogley um i want to say
um i made something for you because
we have very little in common but one
thing we do share in common and
last night i stayed up many hours and
drank many bull rats and made this for
you okay
hello guys um i have prepared for you
charles a song and i know that you is a
nike man you know just do it and but i i
think
perhaps you are not perhaps you are an
adidas man
adidas because all day
i dream about snacks
oh yes let's see kale
i thought i heard donut kale i thought i
heard donut
cardio or donut cardio
salad i thought i heard that salad
i thought vitamins
vitamins
[Music]
is
thank you very much i will send it to
you guys thank you so very much and
wonderful calling of the games
congratulations to nick nurseries and
coach of the year and everyone's very
exciting
thank you thank you much we look forward
to it we look forward to your next
appearance on conan by the way
and and here if you can see it here's
the elevator
yes elevator wow
throw it down
finger guns the shorts these smuggling
grapes
the shorts were an issue yeah
thank you very much we appreciate your
time great to meet you
thank you chuck that is that's a wrap
around
[Music]
here charles and draymond and shaq and
for flulaborg this is ernie johnson
we'll see you again tomorrow night